ええええええ
yeah yeah
me
[音楽]
本当は今日はさんこんにちは
ラーメンくっ
えっとなんかちょっと今日は最初暗い話から入ろうかと思っています
話し始めさせてください
みなさんこんな事って思ったもんなんですかね例えばあの
自分が選んだけど第二外国の授業と
のクラスとか例えばあの
よくわかんなくけど当時についてちゃったサイトサークルの中とかなここめっちゃ居
づらいなんて
claska 映画うわ桁勝った時のクラスとかここなんか居づらいなぁ早く帰りたい
なぁみたいな
なんなら入ってゲームしたいなんていう
神流湖と思ったことをであったりしますよねー
僕がでこれこそすごく感じるタイプだったんです
なんかそこにもちろん当たり前のように楽しんでるたちもいるんですよ
いるんですけどそこにいる自分がすごく異物に感じる
そんな瞬間って感じたことはありますかねえ
今日のスピーチのテーマはこの時代の集まりというテーマでお話をしたいと思ってます
ですね
はいえーと申し遅れました当時ご紹介させていただきますまああのキムヒョンチョルと
申します
青果株式会社という会社を2013年に創業して大学卒業する創業者ですよ
越冬後は全テクと言う会社の取締役使用法とし息をやっています
先ほどご紹介だいたとおりのことはここに書いてあります
ね僕が一番自分の減退必要には自分が在日コリアン3世として夜中に生まれたという
ことです
在日コリアン3世第一これを聞いたことありますなんかてあげてもらえると
大規模いるな
ありがとうございます
まあ要は中食ピンチのときにえっと父親と雨ソフトそこがまああの日本に来て
で父親と刃が生まれて僕が生まれたと言うそんな存在なんですけれども
越冬
ちょっと幼少期から離しますよ初期僕は訳あって鎌倉で生まれたんですが訳あって新潟
のメーカー待つという場所で幼稚園を過ごしましょう
エマーソン時は別にも国籍とか関係ないので目の前にあるものが一つは楽しくて
ただただ
無邪気入れましたそんな無邪気に行って楽しかった幼稚園時代っていうかありました
ですね小学校から朝鮮学校という民族学校に通うことが
ということになりました
このタイミングで朝鮮学校からために名古屋に技が引っ越したんでしょ
いいですねただ幼稚園で1回超日本の文化に馴染んじゃったのでちょっとなんか自分の
中で幼稚園自体もあの民族学校あるんですけどちょっとこう
どんな出来上がってる分間て願って
自分入り込むこと自体がちょっと遺物だなーっていう
自分自体が異物を乗り越えようとちょっとこう
ひたすらまあたまたま頭良かったですよね高さは良かったんで
めちゃくちゃ勉強とかしてひたすら心スポンサーも頑張って
だか努力によって異物感を乗り越えを受け
ことを頑張っていました君
ですね今度中学校一年生です
小泉総理大臣という保存とかた
2000年に小泉想定の総理大臣が初めて北朝鮮と言うか国に行きました
その時にですねこれは国交正常化交渉だったんでしょ
国交正常化交渉ってまあ北朝鮮と日本に国庫ができるかもしれない交渉たんですけど
その時に起きたのが拉致問題の発覚です
中学校小さなにすごい多感な時期に拉致問題の発覚が起きて在日コリアンの僕はの朝鮮
学校の土地とかって結構普通に拉致問題でないと思ったんですよ
なんでないってことかっていうと日本の情報方式では俺に聞けばいいじゃんって
父親も母親もパニックすよね論理的にないと持ったものがあってしかも人道的悪かっ
たっていう
くりパニックでなんかも韓国籍になる人たちもいっぱい出し
を日本席を選ぶともいっぱいいたし自分たちが存在していいのかなみたいなことを
感じるっていう
中古それ以上にもいろいろありました
例えば僕が中がここの時って拉致がわかったと思えばこんなミサイル飛ばし
ミサト場所学校にではくるんですよなんか
学校でなくて学校からお前ら爆発するぞバカさせるぞみたいな
なのに今は日常茶飯しなりすぎて非難もしないですよね
そんな流れで後核の問題は期待とか
高中学校高校で一番多感な時に自分って存在がそもそも何か世界トップすごい物だなっ
ていう
まあグッズに行ったことない国だったんでその時その何ともないですよとは関係ないと
も言えないんで
明日後異物感を感じていました
ねまあその時の言葉を音を自分が思ったことっての一言で言うと
自分にただありのまま普通にでい
なんか小京都かぼ国っていろんな場所いけば背負ってないんじゃないかなんてああ
ことを中高生の頃持っていて様は先ほど話したあ
なんか
ここはちょっとなんだ居場所じゃないんじゃないかなっていう
で最初に冒頭に話した話は僕自身の話です
僕はもう結構どこでもそれを感じていて幼稚園からも反していたしあの焼天弱っちいか
証拠に入った時も完成水
そっからえっとまぁ日本大学に入っても今大口径バックに入りましたけど
何だろうキー1学年60人しかないところから一気に1000人と仙人とか2002
通り入っていってまぁ遺物ですよ
今日はコミュニティの発症するって言いましたなんでこの遺物の端を込め鬼無茶って
いうと僕がコミュに捉えるとコミュニティがまあいろんな込みと出会うことによって
自分が異物だろうと思っ解体してきたっていうそういうストーリーなんですけど皆様
大事にしているコミュニティ家族以外にありますか
ありがとうて方お腹さすがっいっぱいー
そうですねまぁそれコミュニティで ok で黒じゃなくてもなグループとかずっとも
とか
そんな感じですね
僕にもありましたこれデッド xk を2013です
ここには僕数
ねぇそこらへんに何か僕のテックス系お仲間来てくれています
あのん男女にスピーカーの話を一緒につくっていくだけですを楽しくて
だからただただありのままにすごい深めていくっていう作業がすごく楽しかったんです
こんな舞台を作ってました強固なんですけどきた鑑定場所の交差でやってません
例えばあのこの時登壇してくれて僕がスピーチ所に作っていった福井君って強さと
テックス系をハイスクールっていう
まあ高校受講でテックスを開いてくれたりとか
であるいは2015年に xk を言って形で投資かかったメンバーがだしてペットを
つくってくるだけ金
ん
でまあすごい仲いい友人も出来てから歌舞伎役者なんですけれども
あの中村壱太郎さんというかたねー
今でも速射祝させていただいております
分
そういう意味でねー
何だろうテレックス体を今競歩の by ちゃってる落とす嬉しいぞ
なそうなつながってくるって言うことをで教祖換算まずします
もう一個すぎなコミュニティがあります第1部からいた方が話きいたことあるけど文明
作ってコミュニティがありまして服3期で入ったんですけどちょっと専任の帯地会の
運営もちょっとしました
2010年入塾して16年から19年に帯地会の運営をしてました
ん
例えばこんな感じでなんか大学と入ると62河川になんで一方的に切れ授業に意味が
わかんなかったんだぞ
結構ベッドの込めてほしくてこの観光いろいろみんなと話しまくるんじゃなかった
なかったっていう
でここでもこんなイベントをしたりと思う
懐かしい散歩2年前ですねうん文明国等大事なコミュニティ
なんで大事だったかっていうと自分が自分が仕方が振る舞ってなきゃのに
だから誰かが喜んでくれる
ただありのままに行けるん日誰か喜ばせることができる
それっていい場所じゃないかなってこの中で思っていました
いつのまにかいい罰じゃないちゃんがいれば書っていうのがあってそこがすごく僕に
とって
国とか地域に国境はなかったんですけどそういう
あるがままで行っても良い小道っていうのはああ
僕にとって国境って言っていいんじゃないかなと思ってましたん
でそこから会社を立ち上げます僕のミッションも菓子のミッションも世界中を境にする
です
皆さんえっと今
個人のこの地帯ですごいています
1年生を言って聞きましたけど
例えば泊8日フリーランス米ちょっと増えてるんですよね
その大企業にずっと務めるっていうイメージがあんまわからない人ってすぐ増えてきて
いいます
でも僕は小銭残っているかはここをとか孤独箱持つたじゃないか結構思っています
なぜかというと
まあ何だろう例えばこずに残っていても
例えばいいフレーズですごい有名な人の真似をし続けるとか
ソフトはいっぱいでも
もっともっとオリジナリティを持って自分で頑張ってたがやっぱほんといてそういう
ここをであり続けていない
オリジナルであってさらに結果が必要な時代
になってきてるなというふうに思っていますすごい来づらいですよね
でも逮捕生のためにも死者となかったりする
でそれってのはどういうことだというとお酒の話いただけると異物利害物であり続ける
こと
なーんーまぁそこに価値が生じてしまう時代になってきてるんです
でも異物とっても人間なんすよあれ
まあ孤独バカちゃいたいとか共感したりたいとかってお前は絶対誰決まって a
まぁ僕も者発に思ってはいたし
だから逆にあのこの際だからこそコミュニティの時代て最近はってんですよね
一番有名なのはフェイスブックが f 8っていう発表があったんですけど
2018年からコミュニティーづくり新しいミッション
し始めています
あとはまあ持続可能なコミュニティって言葉は去年ぐらいからすごく流行り始めました
ん
では思いを持ったんですよ本当に恋ちゃん者やのっ
これは僕も玄たいげ実態に行きます
約1000人のコミュニティの上教えたって言うんですけど202302の頃まだ
良かったんでしょ
あると顔も見えるし
のなんか
コミュニティそんなにけどてないんじゃないかなって思いのことが増えていったんです
ね
えっ
様子てしまった桜コミットメントが高いとのバントにストック依存する
要するに皆さんが好きなサークルとかゼミとかたぶん真ん中支えてくれてるとはなかっ
たら誰も続かないんですよね
そう言って辞めちゃったらどうすんのっている自分がありますかっていう
いつまでそんな状況続けますが続き言いますか
あるいはそういう金も誰かと合わせますかって言う
ちょっとその価値って話コミュニティを勝つとか消費ではしだして総括の生産と食に
ついてちょっと客観的に考えました
万能徒歩今日このイベントもそうですけどばには価値があって僕話してるかなんて誰も
生産があるんです
ん
ね今日素晴らしいとの三方がみんな生産してくれているそれを消費してくれてるとか
いるから
バワーがります来てくれてありがとうます
なんですけど
本当にいい子見ていってのはそれが消費した人がまた何か生産者いかん
生産者が消費者側にもあったりとかスチームして入れ替わり続けることが本当に
コミティアと僕は思ってますけどそんなるわけじゃないよね
タントにまあ
生産者と消費者の距離ってすごい開いていっ停車したが固定されてしまう
するとただただ義務が生じるんです
いたかった場所か
義務でいなきゃいけない場所になってしまう
僕が経験したあのさっきダック the 文明10回の帯地会運営はこんな感じでした
そして僕はこの2019年3月に一度胸を閉じました
ん
要するに僕は呼吸を一つなくしました
じゃあどうしようってこの時にでも続いて欲しいぞその他の仕事にぱなしっ
じゃあ僕はコミュニティを経済気にしちゃジャパンっていうアイディアを持っていまし
た
これから事ってありますけど
だったんすけど僕のコミュニティ2を依存3年かなでも仕事いっぱいました
なんか大分の林業家についてってレンギョウ体験をさせてもらって
20人ぐらいちゃったんですよねそこにしかないよう体験そうね
例えばまあ千葉にある某国民ってテーマパークの上で会社の方
ねぇあのあまあ案内をしてもらう
普通に仲お金払ってもいいだけなんじゃないかと
僕はもんですじゃあ
これ上が僕が今やってる事の全体像なんですけど真っ黒の反射さっきしました
ん
要はコミュニティを経済喧嘩する方によってコミュニティが続く事って無いかなという
のか
僕の思いになりました
って何やってるかアプリ作っています
コミュニティを小さな経済にするアプリっていう d でおります
聞いてちょっとかわいいじゃないですか
[音楽]
ねうるか集まるつ作っているコンセプトやってます
何やってんのって浅瀬のコミュニティの中でまぁ自らのさっき例えば
まあ某テーマパークを案内するとかそういう体験やスキル
あれはもののバイバイイベント客ができようにするをタップです
で売るか集まるから続くなんで続くかっていうと
コミュニティお金が歓迎されません
これは国と同じデー
viber が来たら消費税が生じる見ていっ
コミュニティの運営にお金を歓迎しますしましょうといえば
モデルです
具体的にどういうことってますの売買についた上の方で扱ってます
ん
えーっと簡単に言うとさっきの反射もそうですけどその場にしか出ないような商材って
あるんでそれを享受できです嬉しいです
かつそれが買えば買うほど今日は元気になる
ものを1個上でやっていて売り上げの一部が今一に考えることによって小道月作っ
二里にどういう仕組みですかって話ですけど普通にコミュニティをつくったりショート
受けることができます
出品して時の得意なことは案内という体験をしたりします
購入されるとコミュニケーションを生じたりデビューは俺がフィードに流れるので今日
の中で口コミ頑張ります
で売り上げの一部はコメントに歓迎されて歓迎されたのかにからもっかいてっと平子
ようって言われたらお金が払われる
仕組みを作っています
具体的な出品者なんですけど例えばわー
くるま旅のベンチャーがってる子かあの格安グランピング提供してくる大丈夫ん
例えばヲタの家元が落ちたらお茶のたて方直接教えますので
経済圏って何かっていう破産とまぁ星人が消防団ってみんな徳井が集まって特によっ
てこ味噌汁塗装いいんじゃないかなっていうことを考えているんです
しかしながらコミュニティや箱か違う破産得意なのもやりとりするだけじゃそんなない
かね
冷徹な話なくてたださっきのさせないけど
ありのままに入れたちが集まることにも価値があるかさ
そこを注ぎ着手します
方ですね私にどういうことやって乗ったしたんすけど
今までなんか飲み会やるときにもう一人とか二人よくインセンティブダメな子ですか
3人だそうなさんに集まろうとそれって店側からすると4人席に2人や3人で去って
るっていうそのプロセスが生じています
だから
4人集まったりとかな宴会場の世界を埋めてくれたらまあお得があるよと割引がきくよ
っていう
モデルをつくってます集まるだけで仲良くなってコメディ俺あってしかもお店にも見せ
アクティビティもお金が生じるっていう
モデルを注ぎ12月からやる予定です
僕の考え込みと未来は集まるだけでただありままに入れるだけでみんなとさせるだけで
大事な呼吸が続いてみんなの力を借りられるそんな未来を描いています
僕らのメッセージは誰かの大事な居場所がなくならないように続くように増えるよ
そんなメッセージで会社をやってます
最後に僕の大事なコミュニティいくつか紹介させください
これ去年の行ったイベントで外果たすん
これも僕の会社の3社に5周年か
最近ですねさっき用チェーン刃ショップいたんですけど幼稚園の時の
ようちゃんと機械と間違ったことを18年ぶりにえっと第二世いっしょあってスーパー
エリートサラリーマンあったんですけど最近うちの会社に同意してくれて役に入りまし
た
この左側の男です
こんな風にコミュニティの価値って次にまた会えるとか
次の交差点でまた出会い治せるみたいな事があんじゃないかなって僕は思ってます